Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be video All about how the
flash can defeat savitar This season.
A lot of you are also asking about Eddie Thawne
stuff so I'll talk about that at the end of
the video but there is going to be a new round
of the flash ring giveaway when I post my
flash video.
Just be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Make sure you click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss it.
In order to defeat's savitar there couple
really important steps along the way in a
couple things that have to happen.
So, one savitar is a being that exists in
this state between life and death who is almost
complete speed force.
That's how powerful he is.
That's why his lightning is white.
So it's not like you could just stab him and
he would bleed out in that be the end of it,
it also involves Barry learning about his
true connection with the speed force they
kind of started that the season you learned
a little bit about that.
So the next big important idea is that Barry
will have to die in a sense this season.
There's a couple different ways that you can
die he's already shown that he's willing to
do anything to save Iris.
And that includes giving up his own life there
really three big ways that Barry could die
this season on the flash one savitar is able
to kill him outright he's pretty fearsome
already Barry is already proven that he's
not enough to defeat him by himself two Barry
could offer himself as a sacrifice, to try
and save Iris.
And then three he could also try to pull savitar
back into the speed force become pure energy
himself and try to battle him across space
time for the rest of existence just to contain
him that he couldn't hurt the people that
he loved that last one becoming pure energy
all address at the end of the video because
it has to do with how savitar is able to manifest
his speed force armor.
So I'll explained that at the end of this
we gotta talk about Barry rushing to judgment.
If there's anything you prove last season
is that he's really good at rushing and before
he completely thinks through all the possibilities,
I know there were a lot of comments last year
after Barry willingly gave his speed to save
Wally in the others he'd gone through the
tachyon device he'd finally been able to beat
zoom but then zoom used his humanity against
him he he was the love that Barry has for
all the people around him against them.
There is no one right now that he loves more
than Iris.
So not only are his enemies willing to use
that against him.
This is a critical weak point because of what's
happening to Iris at the end of the season
if they don't change things.
Everybody has all kinds of theories about
how they're going to save Iris may be they're
using one of Harrison wells holograms that
we saw in the previous episode.
They tend to do that on the flash will tee
up an idea and is edgy getting ready to happen
13 up something that will let you know what's
going on with the black flash.
When he eventually shows up to but that's
kind of a separate thing, because the black
flash is death itself to a speedster.
So Barry is going to be learning a lot about
death this season, I know it sounds bad but
it's actually really exciting black flash
is bad ass and he is not zoom zoom became
the black flash.
When we say that he's coming back, he's coming
back is the black flash zoom himself is not
coming back.
But the thing is is that Barry is not successful
or he has to pull a hard left turn go against
the group and sacrifice himself because there's
no way team flash would let him do that.
Give up his own life.
What would happen in the fallout after that
we already know we have Wally West kid flash
on the show the whole thing.
This first half of the season is been in introducing
him in some of the other flash family members
like Jay Garrick and Jesse quick they step
in to fill the void, but the thing is is that
in the comics after a crisis on infinite earths
they tease that in the season two finale,
which I'll explain in the second Barry basically
sacrifices himself to save the universe Wally
West picks up the mantle and becomes the main
version of the flash he wears a red costume
that looks like this.
Now it seems like he's wearing Barry's costume
they change just a little bit.
There few subtle differences like with the
nose piece, but that was the Ginger version
of Wally West you have to imagine the TV show
Wally West is in a mall gum of those two things
in the cool thing about the Ginger Wally West
in the comics.
They just brought back is that he still has
the red costume that looks like a version
of his yellow kid flash costume and they tease
that were going to see a future version of
something that's really special and comic
book he.
They didn't say which show it was going to
be from what it could totally be a future
version of Wally who has already picked up
the mantle of flash and is wearing a red version
of the costume now.
The other option is future version of Barry
Allen the whole idea of the season is that
he's trying to kill Barry.
And even though there will never be a flash
TV show without grant Gustin Phil always bring
them back what they do is they find ways to
show you potential futures or alternate realities
like earth two or three earth.
19 where things went very very different.
They have a lot of ways to make things happen.
But then take them back.
So even though the TV shows combining a couple
Mark Wade story arcs to do the back half of
the season is terminal velocity which the
story about how they learn what the speed
force is and how Wally West that version.
The flash becomes fully powered and in the
savitar arc which came a little bit after
that but obvious he they change the way that
savitar look season armored speedster it actually
done something really cool with their combining
ideas from those Mark Wade stories where the
Wally West version of the flash who is the
only flash of the time.
Barry Allen is still dead and gone.
People don't know that he's coming back later.
So they don't know what the speed force is
yet, they just know that they draw from something
that they call the speed field, and it explains
why none of them can run at the same speed
why some are faster than others you learn
about the deep connection that Wally has with
the speed force it's the same for Barry Allen
but you learn how when speedsters die there.
Heaven is the speed force.
They become one with that energy, so Wally
learns that he can tap into that and become
even more powerful but in doing so he will
lose his humanity left to leave all his friends
behind explained a little bit about this in
my flash powers video so at a link at the
end of this basically that's one of two options
that Barry has the season either let savitar
kill him out right or two he become so powerful
that he becomes a God speedster like God speed
or savitar who was dubbed himself the God
of speed and starts to look like him as well.
So this is where we get into the savitar twist
because why does he look like that.
Why does he look like a normal person all
the other speedsters we've seen even zoom
who was crazy fast still wore a relatively
normal leather looking costume.
So what is up with the armor will in the rebirth
comics.
The really cool thing that the Ginger Wally
West, who has come back out of the speed force
tells Barry he sort of makes fun of them a
little bit because he still using the flash
ring to get his suit out he says haven't you
learned about speed force constructs making
the suit directly out of the speed force,
so the suit itself is basically just speed
force manifested into that material.
So he does in the the flash ring and that
is probably why savitar has that armor is
not like he climbs into a suit of armor.
He just manifested himself he wears it around
because that's how he exists the idea that
he's become so powerful that he ceased to
be human, but because of the way he got his
powers Barry was able to trap him in the speed
force in the future, so the whole explainer
about why savitar is stuck in the speed force
if he's so powerful kind of gets into the
logic of the speed force, so I'll probably
do a bonus video for that in the next couple
of weeks once we learn a little bit more about
TV show savitar.
Sometimes they change things.
It's not always exactly like the comics that
I have a pretty solid idea about why that
is and it has to do with the way he's connected
to the speed force in the different way that
Barry and Wally are connected to the speed
force here's the thing though, even if Barry
goes away in present day he gets sucked up
into the speed force and learns to enhance
his power becomes this god of speed himself.
That doesn't mean that Wally would immediately
start wearing the red costume.
I would hope that they would go with this
design rather than have him just where Barry
suit.
So I don't think that it's going to happen
in present day.
But it is totally possible that in a flash
forward, either on legends of tomorrow or
on the flash we will see Wally West in the
red costume calling himself the main version
of the flash in a time.
When Barry Allen has died because when you
talk about the reverse flash is from the 25th
century.
That's from a time when there is no flash
there's no speed force, so the way he gets
his powers really cool, we can talk about
that when he comes back because Geoff Johns
sort of rewrote a lot of his continuity before
flashpoint is this really cool story to I'm
hoping that the TV show does you guys can
let me know though do you think that were
going to get a flash of a version of Barry
Allen dying on the TV show in an attempt to
try and save Iris do think that the gonna
try and play with our heads that way because
each season.
He's lost his powers for brief period of time
in the next logical step would be for him
to give up his life and go into the speed
force to continually battle savitar to keep
him at bay so that he wouldn't be able to
kill the people that he loved.
Like I said, just remember there will never
be of flash TV show without grant Gustin as
the main version of the flash so this is all
just flashes of potential futures that they'll
show us people always freak out when the like
this Wally getting faster than Barry.
Don't worry about that kind of stuff in present
day Barry will always be the fastest version
of the flash just to briefly address the Eddie
Thawne stuff they were posting pictures from
the set like a so good to be back.
So there filming the episode that he's in,
which sounds like it might be episode 18,
but it looks like it might end up being a
flashback.
So when we get some more information, all
talk about it more.
We do know the Eddie is coming back.
So I Dover was really excited about that what's
can happen next is is all probably do a video
for Jerome returning on Gotham he's basically
their defacto new 52 Joker but he's taking
a lot of inspiration from Mark Hamill's version
of the Joker, so I'll explain what's going
on because he basically just came back from
the dead.
So the be that in a new episode of the flash
tomorrow night to while you guys wait for
that to post here for more flash episodes
click here to learn about the flash's greatest
power this season.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you in the next video!